this is making me
really anxious hey everyone i'm abby
sharp
welcome back to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by
squarespace and we
are back with another harper's bazaar
celebrity what i
eat in a day review this time i'm going
to be reviewing
the queen of daytime television kelly
ripa
and side note for some reason literally
the day i went to go film this
the footage had completely disappeared
this video had
dropped off of the search engine on
youtube
but thankfully i still had the link and
i realized they actually unlisted it
so you're welcome now before we get into
it a quick note about my sponsor
if you're not familiar with squarespace
it's an all-in-one platform to run your
business whether you're looking to build
a website
blog online store or use their marketing
tools and analytics
as a busy dietician and blogger myself i
love that squarespace has features that
allow you to schedule appointments
through an online calendar and to set up
email campaigns for
a mailing list it's also easy to
seamlessly pull content directly from
instagram or twitter i mean when
everything in your digital presence is
working together
like this it makes it so much easier for
you to really just focus on your actual
business
you can check out squarespace.com for a
free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
abby sharp to save 10 off of your first
purchase of a website or domain
okay so super quick before we dive in
you can pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating
we will be hearing some potentially
triggering sentiments
from kelly and i will be evaluating her
meals
based on nutritional merit alone which
as you know
says very little about their overall
value
it's also worth just saying that this
format follows a celebrity's description
of what they eat and it ultimately tells
me very little about its accuracy
portions brands cooking preparation etc
not to mention their overall
relationship with food
so take this more as general education
to the masses
not necessarily as specific
recommendations to kelly
and of course don't forget to subscribe
to this channel if you aren't already
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss out on a video
all right folks let's get into it i take
a glass of water and i have something
called get off your acid daily greens
which is spirulina spinach kale
all ground to a powder that you mix into
water
and it is for alkalining your
digestive system kelly's intense energy
is already making me feel a little
anxious like
i can feel the short breaths and like
these tight muscles
it's like she's like existing in this
perpetual muscle contraction even when
she's just like sitting down
to chat and it feels pretty exhausting
so yeah i feel like this is already
going to be a little triggering for you
watching
so just a heads up as for her first
drink i have no problem with green
powders if that helps you get in your
antioxidants
or if you're not a fan of vegetables or
fruit
but i often find that the type of people
who use these types of
products are the kind of people who
really don't need them because they're
already getting a lot of greens in their
diet
am i right but anyways i mean for
something with so
many green ingredients i actually looked
it up and it supplies
pretty insignificant amounts of pretty
much every nutrient except for
maybe vitamin k and vitamin c which
if you get any real green things in your
day or you eat things like eggs
and fish and meat you're probably good
anyways
the bigger issue i have is with kelly's
suggestion of
why she uses it namely because it's
apparently
detoxifying and alkalizing yeah
so the website also suggests that it
will help you gain energy lose weight
improve digestion grow stronger hair
nail skin improve mental clarity and
rejuvenate
skin now notice the little asterisks
which
leads us to the oh so familiar
disclaimer that
the claims weren't evaluated by the fda
of course not
because green powder while totally
nutritious
cannot inherently do any of these things
now i know that i've talked about this
whole alkaline diet ad nauseam
but it's actually impossible to change
the ph of your blood
through choosing more acidic or more
alkaline products
i mean your kidneys actually keep your
blood ph
very tightly regulated if they didn't
we would literally die from eating an
orange
so if there are any health benefits to
eating foods that are alkaline in nature
it's not because of any alkalinizing
magic impact on blood ph
but rather because these typically are
just
inherently healthy foods like fruits and
vegetables
so again drink your green powder because
it's a source of nutrients
if you're low in those nutrients or
because you like the taste
but not because it will alkalinize your
body
next then i have a large coffee with
ghee and i blend it in
the um bullet and while i'm having my
ghee
i have my persona morning supplements
which
is my foundational vitamin my
multivitamin
ginger and my
probiotic okay so i thought we were over
the whole
butter coffee trend i mean that was so
2018
but anyways while most of the alleged
benefits of putting oil or fats in
coffee
comes from mcts found in things like
coconut oil
theoretically adding butter to your
coffee will
also slow its absorption and give you a
more
stable caffeine high however
evidence suggests that even if this is a
legitimate effect
it's likely a pretty insignificant one
as for kelly's choice of coffee fat
ghee is clarified better with the milk
solids removed
that has been used in aerobatic medicine
for its alleged health benefits
but ghee much like regular butter is
predominantly a saturated fat
now whether or not that is a legitimate
issue for heart health
is definitely up for debate as i
discussed in my saturated fat video
right here
one 2016 systematic review and
meta-analysis with a total of over 600
000 participants found that there was
actually a small to neutral effect
of consuming butter on things like heart
disease type 2 diabetes
and all cause mortality however other
studies
have shown that saturated fats like
butter
do actually increase ldl cholesterol so
this means that while there may be
no clear indications that butter is the
main or
sole contributor to these diseases it
can potentially impact markers of heart
disease like cholesterol
now while this study found little to no
effect of consuming butter
it also mentioned that including more
unsaturated fats
do have positive health benefits so does
that mean that you should go to town and
eat more butter or more ghee
probably not i mean too much of anything
isn't really good for you and eating
more saturated fat which has either a
negative
or neutral effect should not really be
the goal
rather according to the research it may
mean that enjoying
a little bit of butter or a little bit
of ghee in your coffee or wherever
may not have the overwhelming negative
health effect on heart health
that we once believed as for the ghee
versus better debate
while gui may have a higher smoke point
and be lower in lactose
since you know the milk solids have been
filtered out
there isn't really any quality research
to suggest that it's a much
more healthy fat compared to typical
butter or
to cream for that matter which of course
is more commonly added
to coffee as for kelly's supplements
she's taking a probiotic multivitamin
ginger and omega-3
no major red flags there however a lot
of people think that you can't take a
probiotic with your coffee because
the heat from the drink will actually
kill off the good bacteria
and while there isn't actually a lot of
strong evidence to determine the effect
of drinking
coffee with probiotics the general
consensus
is that by the time that the coffee or
tea is cool enough to actually drink
it's close enough to the internal
temperature of the body
in which the bacteria is really
accustomed to anyway
so it's not really a big deal anyways
let's see what else she has to say
a green apple cut up and then i
take two tablespoons of almond butter
and a teaspoon of cinnamon i blend it
all together and i put the apples in
there and i eat that like a porridge if
you will
and that is my first chewable food
of the day i can just kind of imagine
kelly like meticulously measures
all of this out you know like making
sure she gets every little
microgram of nut butter out of the
measuring spoon and like
weighing the cinnamon like a chemist
um just my just my my
gut feeling from this interview but i
don't know aside from the compulsive
nature of kelly's first
chewable food this does sound like a
pretty good snack i guess i mean
not really a meal in my books this is a
snack
but we do have some protein and fiber
and healthy fats in the nut butter and
fiber rich carbs in the apple so
yeah despite it feeling like pretty
overly calculated and restrictive
it is a nutrient dense choice i
work out um usually after i wrap for the
day
i work out seven days a week okay so
there's nothing wrong with
having like a regular exercise routine
even working out
daily if that is what feels good to you
and your body
i also feel a need to move my body in
some way
most days of the week and the month and
the year
but rest days are actually just as
important
as working out because it's during that
time off when our body can build
strength
endurance and muscle mass i mean
resistance training for example
breaks our body tissues down and rest
days
allow those muscles and nerves and bones
and connective tissues
important time to rebuild so i don't
know for sure what kind of activity
kelly does but if she did want to do
something
every single day i would suggest
choosing some
gentle stretching yoga or low impact
walking
on one to three days of the week between
some of those
heavier training days okay let's
see some more food big salad of micro
greens
with avocado and toasted nuts on top
sometimes
i have pine nuts sometimes i have
pumpkin seeds
sometimes i have walnuts sometimes i
have cashews whatever i'm in the mood
for
whoa really switching up and being
spontaneous for those nut and seeds
options kelly
we are living on the edge
no but i'm just teasing that does sound
like a really solid salad delicious
i mean we've got lots of healthy fats
from the avocado and the nuts or seeds
and of course fiber and antioxidants
from the greens and the nuts
but considering how green this meal is
i think it's safe to say that it renders
that green
powder from the morning kind of obsolete
avocado toast kick of 2015 to 2017
it was two years where avocado toast was
pretty much the foundation of my diet
and i had it with just about every meal
sometimes
i would fry an egg and add that on top
sometimes
a piece of cheese would accompany the
avocado toast
okay so i am glad to see some carbs in
the toast to
add a little bit more balance to the
salad lunch
but i would still say that we are kind
of missing out on the protein here
especially as a post-workout meal
now we now know that we don't have a
crazy tight anabolic window like we used
to think
so you don't have to have a substantial
amount of protein
you know within an hour post-workout if
you don't want to
but that is if we've had some
substantial protein
on board before doing the workout and
since her breakfast
only had like seven grams for breakfast
she could still use a good boost
post-workout
now she did mention that sun is her
avocado toast is accompanied by an egg
and sometimes by a piece of cheese so
that will help out a little bit
but in general i would say that this
brunch meal of hers
is largely just vegetables a little bit
of carb
and a lot of fat all really healthy
stuff of course
but it's a little same same especially
after all the nut butter at breakfast
i have a feeling that this is kind of
just how kelly rolls
but let's take a look at dinner the
smaller version of the same salad that i
had for lunch
and then i have either mixed grilled
greens
or whatever's in season i try to eat
whatever
is in season in terms of vegetables
and then i have usually some sort of
like
plant protein mixed in there like a
grilled tofu
sometimes i'll have a fried tofu
sometimes i have some sort of tahini
okay so again kind of same same right
we've we've got
more of the same salad we had lunch we
got more vegetables
but hallelujah we do have a solid
source of quality plant-based protein so
i love tofu i love tahini although you
would have to eat a lot of teeny to get
like a meal
portion of protein but hopefully the
serving of whatever she chooses makes up
for the lack of protein
earlier on in the day let's take a look
at snacks
i have handfuls of nuts lots of raw
cashews
lots of raw almonds lots of raw
pistachios
i never eat more than a handful but i
have several handfuls a day
case in point more nuts and i love nuts
so i'm not i'm not
knocking down nuts here but we've had
nuts at the breakfast
not set the lunch not set dinner and
apparently
several handfuls of nuts in the day but
never more than a handful she says
never more than a handful that is
kelly's rule
but it seems like kelly has like a
narrow list of
safe foods that she feels comfortable
with that she kind of just
repeats again and again and again
and they're all like super healthy food
so i cannot critique her on that
but she's missing out on multiple
opportunities in the day
to get other nutrients in so she could
easily swap her nut snack one of the
times for like some yogurt berries
or crackers and hummus oven roasted
chickpeas
like you name it there's lots of other
great choices out there
other than just raw walnuts and
pistachios
just saying but at my age now i find
that i it takes too much effort to get
ready
so i just stay ready if that makes any
sense
but in general in general terms i try
not to cheat too much
what i will indulge in is like a
delicious
chocolate covered almond or chocolate
covered cashew some sort of like
so i still feel like there's something
healthy in there
i also have been making a chia pudding
like delicious chocolate chia pudding
okay so
i assume i get ready she means like
keeping her body
in top shape and as a national tv host
i totally understand why she would feel
that desire to like keep herself
consistent
there really isn't like an off season
for kelly
so it does make sense not just for kelly
but really for anyone to try to avoid
weight cycling or yo-yo dieting or
building such an
unsustainable diet that they feel that
they need to
cheat every week so i appreciate that
kelly
isn't necessarily on board with like the
whole cheat day
lifestyle but i also think it's quite
obvious
by the rigidity and repetitiveness of
kelly's diet
that there also isn't really any room
for regular
mindful treats i mean her definition of
a
treat is a chocolate almond or cashew
or it's chia pudding with some cocoa
powder mixed in
so she says when she does treat herself
it has to be something that still feels
like it has something
healthy in it so she feels good about
that choice
maybe this is sustainable for kelly as i
think it's just kind of like a type a
personality
thing but it would probably be really
unsustainable for
a lot of people long term and those
cheat days would probably get completely
out of control
if you were to ask me this one year from
now i will have three entirely different
meals
but it will be the same rotation of
meals
for just about a year
like the same three
meals for a year that's like a whole
year
365 days with no other sweet in her life
other than a sad chocolate almond and
maybe a slice of cake on her birthday
[Music]
i kind of feel sad for her i feel bad
for kelly with this
i am in no way diagnosing anything here
as i get the sense that kelly's just
like got this intense type a personality
she likes to control things she likes to
be meticulous
but i have to also address the elephant
in the room and that is that this
whole interview is screaming orthorexia
an interview that actually got unlisted
for whatever reason
now if you don't know what orthorexia is
it's an unofficial eating disorder
described as
healthy eating taken to an extreme it
generally
is characterized by extreme
inflexibility
perfectionism fear of processed or junk
foods
extreme routine around meals and foods
and like compulsively checking nutrition
labels and ingredients
i know about it really well because i
suffered from orthorexia myself as a
teen
so as somebody who lived it
i can hear my old voice in people all
the time
now again i am not insinuating that this
is something kelly struggles with
at all but i'm just flagging this
because i don't want viewers to think
that
this diet while objectively super
healthy
needs to be the only healthy way to eat
because for some people myself included
this level of dietary purity and
inflexibility
would be pretty triggering and
potentially kind of dangerous i also
want to just
kind of remind everyone how important
variety is
in your diet even more so than choosing
exclusively healthy foods in my opinion
as a dietitian
because when you're only eating a
handful of foods every single day for
365 days of the year
even if they are like super healthy
there's no way you're giving yourself an
opportunity
to expose yourself to every different
micronutrient and antioxidant
no one needs to get in every single
nutrient every single day but the idea
is that if you're switching things up
regularly
you're much more likely to meet your
needs over the course
of a week or a month or over time and if
kelly did that
she probably wouldn't need all of those
supplements now kelly closes off the
interview by saying that she takes some
cbd
before bed which is probably the most
exciting thing i heard the woman say the
whole
interview long but also kind of not
surprised that she needs to take
something to help her relax at the end
of the day
like that i kind of feel anxious just
like
listening to her talk so i can imagine
that tension
probably does take some time to shake
off
anyways in conclusion i want to remind
everyone that this is not
a dig at kelly i have been a kelly ripa
fan
since the early days with regis rest in
peace
i used to watch their show religiously
when i had cable
and i think she's adorable and beautiful
and so
funny but her diet is so intense
i think that's the word of the day
intense and i want people to know that
we can still feel great
and even look great if that's your goal
without the need to
eat the exact same meal or handful of
foods
365 days of the year
and on that note thank you again to
squarespace for sponsoring this video
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up
leave me a comment below with some of
your thoughts also
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and i will see you next time on
abby's kitchen
bye
you